(en anglais)
- L'imprévisible
multimilliardaire Elon Musk
est un habitué des coups
d'éclat, mais cette fois-ci,
il s'est surpassé.
Hier soir, le nouveau
propriétaire de la plateforme
sociale Twitter a sondé
l'opinion de ses 122 millions
d'abonnés. Sa question :
"Dois-je quitter la direction
de Twitter?"
Ce matin, la décision
est tombée : 17 millions
de personnes ont voté et plus
de 57 % veulent qu'il cesse
de diriger Twitter, un réseau
qu'il a acheté il y a à peine
deux mois pour 44 milliards
de dollars.
Ce résultat est probablement
en lien avec les multiples
décisions d'affaires
controversées qu'Elon Musk
a prises depuis son arrivée.
ANDRÉ MONDOUX, professeur,
École des médias, UQAM
- Twitter, c a a aussi
un service collectif, si je peux
dire. Or, la première chose
que M. Musk fait en rentrant,
c'est de mettre du monde à pied,
fermerépépépépartements qui
étaient garants d'une certaine
hygiène informationnelle,
si vous me passez l'expression.
- Plusieurs observateurs
estiment que le milliardaire
n'est tout simplement pas
la bonne personne pour gérer
efficacement un média social.
ALAIN SAULNIER, auteur et expert
en journalisme et médias
- Moi, je ne pourrai jamais
accepter, puis je l'ai s
écrit, je pourrai jamais
accepter que des
multimilliardaires décident
de qu'est-ce qui est bon
ou qu'est-ce qui est mauvais
à mettre sur unu u u u social.
C'est inadmissible.
Mais on se retrouve dans cette
situation-là, aujourd'hui,
où ces gens-là ont ce droit
de vie ou de mort sur la liberté
d'expr
- Malgré les résultats
du sondage, Elon Musk n'a pas
encore officiellement annoncé
qu'il quittait la direction
de Twitter.
- S'il est conforme à sa parole,
il devra quitter comme PDG,
mais qui c'est qui veut
ueueueueuer dans cette
aventure-là, et surtout,
est-ce que M. Musk va rester
dans les pattes du nouveau PDG
ou de la nouvelle PDG?
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, Montréal